welcome to Rimes City a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct
if you are anything like your town
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
come in there whoever you are
you know how to use this jeez here we go
I know you can't understand me but put
down the stapler or I will electrocute
you did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me it'd have been so lousy
they try to talk to me all the time all
they hear is pika pika you can hear him
right guys adorable you're adorable they
can't understand me kitchen no one else
I don't need a Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
[Applause]
that brought us together and that man
Turkey is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie they dropped
the first detective Pikachu trailer so
we got to break it down Ryan Reynolds is
Pikachu he was dropping all kinds of
memes earlier poke a pool so I'll
explain what's going on with the plot in
like the crazy number of Easter eggs if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll
find some fun giveaway to do but the
movie isn't coming out till next summer
so it's gonna be a little while before
we get another trailer the actual
synopsis of the movie reads the story
begins when a Sutekh t'v harry goodman
goes mysteriously missing prompting his
21 year old son tim to find out what
happened aiding in the investigation is
Harry's former Pokemon partner detective
Pikachu
hilarious wisecracking adorable super
sleuth who is a puzzlement even to
himself finding that they are uniquely
equipped to communicate with each other
Tim and Pikachu joined forces on a
thrilling adventure to unravel the
tangled mystery chasing clues together
through the neon lit streets of rhyme
city a sprawling metropolis where humans
and pokémon lives side by side in a
hyper-realistic live-action world they
encounter a diverse cast of Pokemon
characters and uncover shocking plot
that could destroy this peaceful
coexistence and threaten the whole
Pokemon universe so Pikachu's partner
here goes missing his son who was once
an aspiring pokemon trainer but washed
out of the program tries to pick up the
task of finding him and I'm guessing the
twist that allows him to speak to
Pikachu but not other people has
something to do with the magic that
binds Pokemon to this universe it allows
them to coexist but we got to do Easter
eggs there's a crazy number so we'll
just work our way through the trailer
and even starting with the poster
there's a whole bunch here so you see a
sign for Eevee salon with eby's tail
attached there's a strip of ads for moo
moo milk Johto sport club there's a
place called Charizard there's a
PokeMart sign
there's berry juice there's a sign from
a champs gym there's signs for stores
called you dov'è style J puffs way over
here is a lick tongue there's a marquee
advertising a mr. mime show that's who
they're interrogating at the end of the
trailer where Pikachu just isn't getting
that he's telling him to shove it
throughout the trailer there are
billboards everywhere with all kinds of
Easter eggs because it's obviously a
very urban area so you see in the
background here Pokemon Vicente looper
pedal lil goomy
Psyduck Gengar Jigglypuff this character
here is just called Lucy she's a junior
reporter following her first big story
so she just probably catches on with
their Chase to try and find his father
in his room you see posters for the
championship battle at cerulean arena
there's Blastoise Charizard there's a
poster for a battle between hypno and
Dragon Knight there's a poster for judo
sports club with art Akeno its steelix
there's a poster for Charizard Blaziken
Flygon in a three-way battle there's an
ad for the 24th Sinnoh Championships
there's a poster for Reshiram and Zekrom
that are fighting each other and then
obviously his headboard is Pikachu's
ears there's a funny Easter egg on the
ticket here it's a one-way ticket to
Rhyme City but the departure stop is
leave town as in he's leaving town to go
to rhyme city so just a joke there
there's a bunch of Emolga in the
background of this shot there's
Bulbasaur and mourlot walking through
this river here this is Jigglypuff on
the table here there's this giant battle
with Charizard where it looks like
Pikachu actually gets in the ring with
him
these are greninja's swiping their claws
across the frame this is rough let
another squirtle then there's an
extended scene with him trying to
interrogate mr. mime at the end of the
trailer overall it seems pretty solid
people did not know what to think when
they first announced this project like
wait a minute is this gonna be like
another live-action anime adaptation is
also really confusing when they say
mixture of live-action and CG because
you just don't know what that's gonna
feel like - you actually see footage but
the execution on this does look pretty
good and you know fun Easter egg here -
if you remember when Deadpool 2 came out
they were doing all those jokes with
Ryan Reynolds and Green Lantern Warner
Brothers was tweeting jokes at him to
like give us the ring back Ryan for
whatever reason they were getting in on
the fun usually you don't expect Warner
Brothers corporate account to get in on
jokes like that usually just let Ryan
Reynolds do his thing like he likes to
make fun of himself all the time no big
surprise there please don't make the
supersuit green
or animated universe but I think what
was going on is is that because they
were working on detective Pikachu and
it's being released by Warner Brothers
they wanted to show him a little bit of
support for Deadpool to just to help
their relationship when they were
getting ready to promote this movie so
even though on the surface it seems like
a DC versus Marvel thing when Brian
Reynolds makes Green Lantern jokes you
have to remember that he does make a lot
of movies with Warner Brothers pictures
which owns DC so at the end of the day
behind the scenes everybody is friends
and it's all in good fun but the last
real big experience that I had with
Pokemon was actually when Pokemon go
first came out way back in summer 2016 I
played it for a little while and I
haven't really picked it back up since
most of my experience with the fandom
was when the first movie dropped and the
games hit Gameboy back in the late 90s
so it's been a long time since I've been
like a really huge Pokemon fan but it is
fun to revisit it every once in a while
like usually when there's a new game
I'll check it out for at least a little
while let me know what you guys think
about the trailer and let me know when
you jumped on the Pokemon franchise like
way long time ago or more recently with
Pokemon go
I think Pokemon go blew up so big that
it just introduced a whole lot of new
people to the franchise I'll do more
videos for this as we get more trailers
maybe one before the end of the year but
it's not coming out till next summer so
most of the stuff we see for it will be
next spring what's happening later
tonight is I'll post a new flash episode
video after it airs there was a new
trailer for the big crossover episode
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here for my Stan Lee tribute
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight
that brought us together and that magic
is called hope